trump and desantis
adam said i want to know if this is the
truth i want to hear from david harris
so we're going to see what david harris
has to say about this and we're going to
see what uh
mr sauce has to say about this so trump
reportedly said he often hates ron
desantis this is a the weak story
as former president trump possibly as a
2024 run a new report suggests there's
one other potential contender whose
popularity he really resents florida
governor desantis a report from vanity
fair this week delves into our various
republicans are testing the waters for
2024 presidential primaries in case
trump doesn't decide to seek the gop
nomination and among the likely
contenders in that scenario would be
descendants but the report describes
that the
fact that the florida governor's biggest
challenge may be his fraught
relationship with the 45th president
trump often hates the santa say trump
confidante told vanity fair he just
resents his popularity earlier this year
2024 straw poll taken at the western
conservative summits of the santa
slightly ahead of trump 74 to 73
so i'm going to go to you first have you
heard anything about the story david
harris jr no
and my first question when you asked me
last night if i even knew about it was
who reported it
because i've got a filter that i've got
to put everything through and every
single individual in america literally
in the world should understand that
you've got to put things through a
filter who's saying it what's their
source uh and is anybody else verifying
that and what's their angle you know
what is the which way do they lean vandy
fair leans
heavily left so far left maybe furthest
left you know they're in the category of
furthest left yeah they're out there
with rolling stone who just got smashed
for uh uh posting a fake news article
against ivermectin saying that hospitals
in ohio were overran with uh uh with uh
people having adverse reactions to
ivermectin so much so that people that
had car accidents couldn't get in there
the whole thing was made up the whole
thing was a lie uh rachel madd maddow
mad cow she ran with it bbc ram with it
so anyway i have a filter so my my
question is who's saying the article
okay they're left-leaning biased
reporting uh agency and what would their
intention be for this
um well
try to create some division amongst uh
uh conservatives or at least two
democrats make it look like the higher
ups trump desantis are at odds with each
other i haven't personally heard
anything i've reached out to some
connections that that are close with
trump i haven't heard back
from them but uh it doesn't make any
sense to me you know defenses is doing
exactly what you know he's an american
first america first uh governor
he's leaving the state open he's trying
to leave the state open he's allowing
people to go to work
they're seeing you know their numbers
soar as far as employment um they they
have so many hit pieces against them on
you know the virus is out of control in
florida and then they wind up having to
retract all that because it was total
made up like they literally took data
from last year and plugged it into this
year to try to make it look like they
had a massive resurgence of of covet in
florida so there's a
there's an attack to try to separate and
to make trump look bad or make the
sanders look bad but i haven't heard any
of that and i don't i don't i don't see
that either and i definitely don't see
him actually making a statement that
would go anywhere even if he did for
some other personal reason to have an
issue with the sanders yeah so so you
buy into the comment that obama said uh
don't underestimate uh biden's ability
to f things up oh yeah i can believe
that because yeah i mean can you see
that happening
doing something like that he's one of
the greatest uh
presidents we've had in the last 12
months well yeah i'm sorry 81 million
people voted for for the guy most
popular president of all time yeah yeah
as he couldn't get 50 people to his
rally which is why they had to start
using jeeps to go in there and honk so i
want you to be careful because he gets
offended when you say things like that
adam gets voted all i do is speak the
truth david harris can i ask you a
question sure odds that trump runs in
2024 what you got
i say they're very good i don't want to
hear very good i need numbers baby i'd
say it's 90
90. i don't think that's the question
though i think the question isn't that i
think the question is
who
on the right do they want to be the
leading candidate representing the 2024
meaning
do republicans today want trump or do
they want desantis
they want trump okay so let me ask you
the base that trump built
and the the energy that's in the
conservative party and there's a
splintering right because trump was the
outsider so the gop i mean it's like
there is a splintering in the gop from
the republican party that would rather
have desantis they'd rather have the
same sure yeah than trump they say well
trump's too polarizing this that and the
other but you know what i think more
people in this country are fired up to
be conservative and to align with
conservative values which is what
republicans do than ever before in this
country here's a question for you so say
for instance trump says i'm not running
do you think trump will go campaign for
desantis or desantis to win
if if desantis is the is the guy i think
he would yeah you think he would yeah so
you know like he is right now with state
uh with uh with congressional races he's
endorsing candidates he's out there he's
pushing you know he said he's not gonna
he he's not gonna just take this this
loss this perceived loss i mean it is
right on paper we got a president on
paper right now
that's in there because of fraud and my
personal belief and opinion is
absolutely no way that he should be in
office
and i'm still holding out for the
arizona audits i'm still holding out to
find out what the audits have to say
uh because i believe that when the
audits come out of arizona they're going
to decertify their results that's going
to be numb the first state to do it and
then georgia's fault i think georgia's
going to follow suit with the audits
wisconsin's talking about it
pennsylvania what are you asking all
those swing stops
dave you know what on my podcast the
david j harris jr podcast on my podcast
for a year
yeah you got to have jay can i have the
j and j
james james david james it's kind of
like two bible names right
well it's just my songs
david james harris jr keep going so um
for the better part of a year
on my podcast i would say if for some
hail mary chance of a reason joe biden
got in office
well he's in office
so now i'm saying if if there's a hail
mary chance
that we can get these swing states
to actually do a forensic audit and look
if biden won then all power to him great
everybody that's supporting biden
supports the democrats they should be
happy they should be able to say look we
proved it now shut the hell up
great but if not why are they
roadblocking and stalling these audits
from happening well you're using term
like hail mary so this is a hail mary
well it is yes
what i'm saying right now is what i
truly believe is a way to rectify the
fraud there's no statute limitations on
until it happens until it happens it
happens i mean i want to stay on topic
here so let's go back on topic here so
how how bad you think it would look
when desantis and trump imagine the
debate stage for republican you know
these two guys are debating okay
you have on stage nikki haley you have
onstage desantis you have on stage pence
you have on stage these guys are
debating right
how ugly will that get if that because
to me the sight of pence and trump
debating that doesn't look right no okay
yeah and do you think desantis
is going to sit there and allow trump to
take shots at him or do you think
trump's going to be okay if desantis is
like you know the kamala harris shot at
biden do you remember the whole thing
like how awkward that was oh yeah the
second was it the first debate or second
debate i don't know
racist basically
which is the final oh i'll come back for
you but but how weird will that look to
see desantis trump hence all on stage
nikki haley makes sense but the other
three to be on stage if that were to
happen how competitive do you think it
would get it
it it almost seems unimaginable like
that's how i agree with that i'm asking
you about what you see pence
desantis nikki haley up on stage
debating trump yeah and let's not forget
what trump haley's 2016. haley's fine
no she's got some questionable yeah no
no no no no
what i'm saying is haley doesn't give a
[ __ ] like to go right now
no no she yeah she'll call her she'll
call him out it almost seems like
they're just gonna give him the
nomination like i don't see trump
remember how ugly things got in 2016
between lion ted cruz and little marco
rubio and the whole cast and sleepy ben
carson and with the whole thing how ugly
it got
i think you know you know what though
with with trump he never really went at
ben
he never went at ben with any shots
carson ben carson yeah he just let ben
be ben right he's literally having a
stage he didn't really have anything to
say i'm almost wondering if that was the
case it's hard to imagine but if that
was the case if we'd actually just see
them each try to lay out their best plan
for how to move this country forward in
the right direction and unless somebody
has a reason for shots like pence
trump's not going to back down off of
that because let me tell you why
he could have stopped the the he could
have given another two weeks back in
january to say we need to actually look
at some of this material instead of
moving forward with uh with certifying
the election and pinstone do it what do
campaign managers get hired to do
to win seek industry for you to win
right not for
for you to win the campaign manager has
a lot on the line if i'm taking desantis
and i want to be your campaign manager
i'm asking you a question dude are you
playing to be vp or are you playing to
be the president right because i got to
have a good record as well
so then trump's campaign manager they're
going to do what they do best they're
going to make those short clips go viral
you know because you'd be in jail type
of videos their their social media team
is a freaking beast of a social media
team right yep so he's going to know his
part but i will tell you the sentence is
not a lightweight the santa is not pants
no santas is not uh nikki haley no no
the santa's desantis believes
he's the president united states the
santas has that identity that i'm gonna
be the president united states and i
think i'm the right guy to do the job i
think that's what this and there's a
part of america that believes the same
with him as well
so he'll get ugly huh
i agree that's my concern yeah let me
show you my two cents here's the other
conversation do you think you know how
biden has a meeting with uh not biden
has a meeting the the the folks on pop
bites camp have a meeting with sanders
with elizabeth warren with everybody
like listen guys super tuesday drop out
come support let's go win we got to beat
this trump guy we can't be dividing
right you think there's going to be
somebody that's going to say desantis
okay so let's have the conversation so
visualize this conversation i'm from
trump's camp i go meet with desantis and
i say hey ron we'd like to have a
meeting with you and they have the
meeting behind closed doors and they say
ron uh how much do you love america you
know how much i love america ron
we think the best thing to do right now
is the following how about you agree
to not go up against trump you become
the vp trump becomes the president
and we go beat biden and then after
trump's done you win and you become a
two-term president
okay visualize that it's gonna happen
yeah you're ron desantis what do you
think ron's gonna say in that meeting
that's tail no yeah
he's gonna say hello
to that is what you're saying no no no
no no no no he's gonna say hell no he's
gonna say like are you crazy it's it's
almost like this it's almost like i
don't know though because he desantis
has to see
the rise in popularity among the
conservatives in the republican party
due to trump the trump effect you can't
deny the manga effect the trump effect
instead of trying to chop trump down and
go after him and potentially lose
he could be a sure bet if he got with
trump and then he could still have the
chance to be president for two more for
two months i don't know if he sees it
that terms i think i don't know it's
tough i think here's what you got to ask
him is he dwyane wade
or is he giannis is he is he
uh uh uh is he a guy that's gonna be
like hey let's team up and go build a
super team together you know like hey
come on let's build a super team in
cleveland and miami and boston or is
your guy that's gonna say no i'm good i
can build a team around myself and i
think i'm a good number one i think
you're good number one but i also think
i'm a good number one
i get a feeling that ron thinks he's a
good number one i don't get a feeling
that i think ron thinks he's a number
two there's there's a moment where trump
is bringing ron up this is in 2019. and
trump says you know i'm not gonna lie to
you first time uh i met ron i i said you
know iran's a little chubby ron's gotta
lose some weight because i was always
worried that ron's a little heavy you
know he's a little round he's a little
happy he said this are you saying
and he says i'm like he says yeah you
kind of feeling him i'm thinking this
guy's a little heavy he's you know he's
got to lose some weight and trump is
saying this about this he says and then
one day i tap his shoulder when i tap
his shoulder and i felt all the muscles
i said no this guy's not chubby this
guy's muscular this guy's strong he's
the only politician i've said this to he
said i told ron ron you ought to take
your shirt off more often don't wear a
jacket with that being said help me
bring up your governor ron desantis
that's how he brought him up
[Laughter]
i actually think that there is kept it
real he kept it real unreal i actually
think there is a little bit of
credibility to this story and i'll tell
you why and i get that it's vanity fair
you know how they say you would yeah
there's credibility to vanity fair he
would no i'm not i don't even care about
the vanities
subscriber to national inquiry just so
you know i'm going based on
track record
you know how they say the ego is not the
amigo
if this poll is anywhere this is at the
western conservative summit
this ain't vanity fair here david yes
this is a straw poll okay cool it's a
poll the fact that we all know that
trump loves the polls i'm doing great in
the polls
yeah that doesn't validate him saying
something like that about this i'm not
that's not what i'm saying all right
together that's what he's trying to do
so that's what i'm saying if there was a
poll that's what people that have been
programmed do what i i'm saying if there
is a poll that even shows
desantis beating trump trump doesn't
like that bro love you buddy okay listen
i think we all agree here here's my
prediction trump went runs again
he's not going to win if desantis and
haley win on the tick uh run on the
ticket they can win i think you're
forgetting how toxic trump is i think if
you take a desantis
and a nikki haley you're going to get
people in the middle to vote for them i
think if you're cool with your 42
percent
you know maybe you get to 45
you're back to oh we got this lecture
stolen from us uh they don't they don't
like trump let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question
go to uh go to uh
anybody after their first term okay
obama after his first term did he have a
terrible first term he did not have a
great first term okay
go to did he have a terrible first turn
i wouldn't have did he have a terrible
second time did he have a terrible first
time what's that did obama have a
terrible first term he did not have a
good first term but not a terrible i
think it was terrible okay so do you
think bush gw had a good first term
uh
junior yeah
no with 9 11. okay
let me continue
do you think uh clinton had a good first
term
yes yes okay
take all of their first terms yes and
even trump do you think trump had a good
first term until kovid but that's not on
his control though because even he
deliberately well he he brought vaccine
within nine months even though everybody
said even found she said 18 months he
delivered within nine months right
that's not because of foundry trump was
dealing with all these other guys that
brought it okay so today if we look at
trump as a fur term first term was it a
great first term good first term
terrible first term or bad first term
depends on the the lens that you're
looking at zero to ten
for uh let's say i was judging it even
for you say five or six sure okay
who between trump obama gw
bill clinton had a worse first term
those four or biden so far i mean just
based on what happened to the country
you have to say george w bush with
katrina with 9 11. okay so you put him
first worst term first term yeah you put
biden uh uh uh biden i mean he's been in
less than a year so it's like it only
took a year for him to break everything
i mean
he didn't need a whole four years some
people don't need four years ago more
competitively
jimmy carter every day thanks god saying
thank you for the favorite president of
all time jimmy carter is officially
taken off the list
he's officially taken off the list i
don't think that biden is doing great
okay
at all
he's less than a year ago i don't know
where i'm going with this where i'm
going with this is you forget the fact
that depending on how biting does he
makes it easy for anybody to say we
gotta try something i don't think biden
should run again in 2024 oh you want
kamala as a partner i know i don't think
he's gonna you want his first term
pelosi
not pelosi i think look i think there
should be a rule if you're over 70 peace
out
peace out for moving forward peace out
really trump biden pelosi so he would
you judge guy
what's that buddha judge no i'm not but
i think he's a talented guy but i'm not
a buddha judge guy i just think
again i'll say this again for those that
weren't listening i think if desantis
and nikki haley run on that ticket they
can win if you throw toxic trouble
independence and some democrats that's
what i'm saying dave all right we all
know that if you're a conservative and
you're a maga guy you love trump
but nobody else does bro
like do you i love that policies it's
not about the man although i appreciate
him okay met him 10 11 times how many
people vote on policies well they're
gonna say they're gonna start to because
of what's going on i don't think so i
think that argument of forget about the
candidate forget about the candidate put
a blank picture of the candidate and
just look at their policies well if we
keep going
i don't think anybody does that i think
it's an emotional
attachment to who the candidate is and
people were emotional there's some
pizzazz in there right somebody gets up
that's the whole world
people want to see somebody and how
they're going to interact how they're
going to talk of course what's the
what's the percentage right now of
people wanting to retract their vote for
20 percent it was 20 right one in five
out of 80 million people that that's
that's enough that's what 20 million
16 million people okay so that alone and
by the way secretly you're part of that
camp as well though no i don't pull the
lever for biden uh again i will tell you
this stop desantis you've override and
nikki haley you have a chance you vote
for biden toxic trump
you have no chance adam yes sir you vote
for biden when
in 2020 yes
okay you regret your vote yet
i don't regret my vote but i think uh
biden has some cleaning up to do
how
all he's done is make messes so far well
like a little kid crapping in his
diapers that's some of the some of the
looks that that biden does after he says
something it's that look that he gets
it's a look a little kid has again this
is how i look at it we've had this
conversation already my the way i look
at it is the following who's a good
number one
okay biden's not a good number one but
nobody voted for him to be like they
they were like we got a drunk driver
someone who's what i'm saying that's why
people what i'm saying today people are
starting to realize you don't vote for
number four to be a number one right you
don't do that correct gerald ford was
never a good number one he's a good
number two or three yeah hw bush he was
never a good number one and that's why
he didn't get uh elected a second time
right who didn't senior senior no no no
he didn't get elected the second time
because he got cocky thinking he's gonna
win roster
all right so that's a very different
anomaly you just brought in no that's he
wasn't really a true number one
uh i think on against the people he was
going up against but i also think ross
pearl was the number one yeah i think
ross pros are number one are you kidding
me i think ross pro was a fully good
number one so you have the look no but
the but it sounds so so the challenge
i'm having right now is desantis is a
number one
so is trump that's what i'm trying to
say pence i don't think pence should run
no i think people behind closed doors
that are telling them to run i think
should say nothing i think should say
just stay there because pence's legacy
right now is not that bad it's not great
but pence's legacy believe it or not
remember when trump first announced
pence what do people say like what pence
yeah
and then you got to know him you're like
you know what and no yeah he's like cool
yeah he's likable and and he's pink
steve has vanilla
but that's exactly what trump trump
means i agree yeah yeah that's why he
was a good selection so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you